but okay so you guys are both pretty
easy on the eyes so my question my
question is is it hard is that kind of
how do you deal with that kind of
difficult I mean I mean I just I get it
with with Michael oh don't you even well
I can barely turn away from these
because I was saying we know you're
married and well he's engaged sorry
ladies but this is why bringing it up
it's the sweetest proposal ever and I
want you to tell everyone and brag about
yourself there was a bit before like
when we were shooting the show that kind
of gave me a bit of a push because I was
kind of in my head about it trying to
figure out what to do but I remember a
scene where I talked about he the get my
character says when something dope comes
along you got to lock it down or else if
you're stuck in your thoughts you'll
miss your opportunity and then get
sucked into the propeller of a swamp
boat but the first part I really took
into consideration and I took her to
different places where where like where
I first saw her where we had our first
date where we had our first acting class
and stuff and I would take her back to
these places and I would have like this
message on a canvas and I'd have a read
it and then we'd go to the next place
and then in the last place got down on
women wasn't your family it was at your
family that would say had signs that
said will you marry me and then you were
on your knees yes so your family was
behind her yeah and they all had a sign
of some when she turned her and said
will you marry me he was on his knees
yeah
I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my YouTube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this